we're gonna go with guns and Senator
Warren I want to start with you we are
less than 50 miles from parkland Florida
we're 17 people were killed in a school
shooting last year and where there has
been significant activism on gun
violence ever since many of you are
calling for a restoration of an assault
weapons ban
but even if implemented there will still
be hundreds of millions of guns in this
country should there be a role for the
federal government as it mike serone
everybody's mics are on i think we have
a I heard that too that's okay
I think we had a little mic issue in the
back control room we've got copy
I think we heard yeah we have the
audience I know right
so the question is simply this we're
talk we're from I apologize you guys
didn't get to hear this the first part
of the question obviously we're not far
from parkland Florida gun activism has
become a big part of high school life up
there in Broward County many of you are
calling for tighter gun restrictions
some of you calling for the restoration
of the assault weapons ban but even if
it's put in place are still going to be
perhaps hundreds of millions of guns
still on the streets is there a role for
the federal government in order to play
in order to get these guns off the
streets we are hearing our colleagues
audio I it's a control room
yeah if the control room can turn up the
mics of our previous moderators we will
[Applause]
guess what guys we are gonna take a
quick break we're going to get this
technical situation fixed we will be
right back